[موسيقى]
العالم بيعيش تحت رحمه مظله ضخمه من
التيارات المقاتله النفاثه بنتكلم عن سوق
ضخم جدا اتصرف وبيتصرف عليه تريليونات
الدولارات السوق ده واللي يمكن حضراتكم مش
واخدين بالكم منه بيمر لفتره دي بتطورات
اقتصاديه مهوله ومدهشه من واشنطن مرورا
بانقره والرياض وباريس ونودلهي وصولا
لموسكو وبكين وجاكرتا بس الاول خليني احكي
لكم حكايه مهمه جدا هنرجع بسرعه لاواخر
الخمسينات تم الاتحاد السوفيتي كان عنده
مشكله ضخمه جدا مع سلاح الجو الامريكي
تحديدا مع طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرع من
الصوت وقاذفات القنابل الامريكيه الجديده
وجود الطيارات دي كان مزعج جدا للسوفيات
اللي مش عارفين هيحموا حدودهم الواسعه
ازاي بما انهم اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث
المساحه ووقتها العالم يا دوب كان لسه
بيتعرف على انظمه الدفاع الجوي بعدها بكم
سنه وتحديدا في اواخر 19
اقمار تجسس امريكيه لقطت شويه صور سببت
رعب في امريكا واوروبا الصور دي كانت
لمقاتله سوفيتيه جديده فتحات محركاتها
بحجم عربيه صغيره واجنحتها طويله جدا كانت
اطول واعرض من اي طياره مقاتله امريكيه او
غربيه الميك 25 وقتها 25 دي خلت
الامريكيين يلفوا حوالين نفسهم لانهم ما
كانوش لسه يعرفوا امكانياتها الحقيقيه
واللي هي في الحقيقه كانت اقل بكتير من
اللي افترضوه الرعب ده خلى الامريكيين
عاوزين طياره اعتراضيه تقدر تعمل كل حاجه
تقريبا تناور وتشتبك من مسافات قريبه اللي
هي اشتباكات دوج فايت وتشيل صواريخ دقيقه
تقدر تصيب الهدف من المسافات دي وعلى
ارتفاعات قليله وتقدر تستهدف الاهداف
المعاديه من على مسافات بعيده برادرات
حساسه وصواريخ موجهه والنتيجه كانت تطوير
وصناعه الاف 15 اجل ان طياره قتاليه في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده لحد اللحظه
والطياره الوحيده اللي لم يتم اسقاطها لحد
النهارده على مدار ال51 سنه اللي فاتوا من
اول طيران لها سنه 1972 الولايات المتحده
انتجت من الطياره دي يا اخوانا اكتر من
1600 نسخه من مختلف الطرزات والشركات
الخاصه الامريكيه كسبت من وراها عشرات
مليارات الدولارات على مدار ال51 سنه دول
ولسه لحد وقتنا ده بتكسب منها مكاسب رهيبه
يعني مثلا شركه بوينج اللي هي الشركه
المنتجه لطائرات اف 15 دي بجميع طرازاتها
بتنتج منها دلوقتي احدث طراز وهي اف 15 اي
اكس تتوقعوا كم تكلفه الطياره لوحدها
معديه ل 115 مليون دولار للطياره الواحده
وفي طلبات كتير على الطياره دي زي مثلا
البحريه الامريكيه هتطلب منها اكتر من 100
طياره والكيان المحتل طلب منها بشكل مبدئي
25 اختيار القوات الجويه واندونيسيا خدت
موافقه الكونجرس الامريكي على توريد 36
طياره منها مع معدات تانيه في صفقه بقيمه
14 مليار دولار ولكن في العموم امريكا مش
هي الدوله الوحيده اللي بتنتج طيارات
مقاتله عندنا روسيا طبعا والصين وفرنسا
والسويد وبريطانيا وكوريا الجنوبيه ومؤخرا
انضم التركيه للقائمه بشكل مفاجئ وغير
مسبوق بالنسبه لمعظم الناس بمقاتلتها
وبشكل جماعي هنلاقي اوروبا فيها مشروعين
مستقبليين كبار لانتاج مقاتلات جيل سادس
ما بين سنه 2030 و2040 منهم مشروع مهم
خطير بتحاول السعوديه بايدها واسنانها
تدخل في كشريك بقى لها شهور ومعاهم مشروع
مشترك تالت لانتاج مقاتله اسيويه بين
كوريا الجنوبيه واندونيسيا ده غير طبعا
استمرار برنامج
تسليح في التاريخ واللي تكلفته هتتعدى
في نص التريليون دولار وانتج لنا بالفعل
اف 35 بكل طرازاتها فاحنا محتاجين نفهم
ايه اللي بيحصل بالظبط ايه قصه الطائرات
المقاتله وليه دول العالم بتتسابق على
انتاجها وبتصرف عليها عشرات المليارات
وايه اهميه التيارات المقاتله بالنسبه
لاقتصادات الدول وليه تركيا وغيرها
بيصنعوا طياراتهم الخاصه وللسعوديه عاوزه
تنضم للمشروع الاوروبي العملاق لانتاج
طياره جيل سادس وهل امريكا هتفقد هيملتها
بالفعل على سوق اهم سلاح في العالم على
الاطلاق تعالوا ندردش شويه وفهمكم اللي
بيحصل انا اشرف ابراهيم المخبه الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه اكسنس العالميه لرعايتها
الحلقه دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في
الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز
الاتنين تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل
مع اكسنس علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها
مرخصه ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه
بعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل
بشري التالته ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفذ بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك لازم تفهموا قاعده مهمه
جدا جدا يا جماعه لما دوله بتبيع مقاتله
فهي مش بتبيع مقاتله حربيه بس هي بتبيع
علاقات كامله مع المشتري علاقات سياسيه
واقتصاديه وعسكريه وامنيه وعلى كل
المستويات اللي ممكن تتخيلوها علشان كده
جه وقت كان في كل الدول الكبرى والمتوسطه
او سن يبنوا طائرات مقاتله خاصه بيهم في
الثمانينات مثلا هنلاقي ان جنوب افريقيا
والبرازيل ورومانيا والكيان المحتل
واليابان والهند وغيرهم كان عندهم مخططات
هندسيه فعليه لطائرات مقاتله محليه عدد
قليل من الطائرات دي اتصنع بالفعل ولكن
باعداد صغيره ومعظمهم اختفى خلال
التسعينات كان في اسباب كتير لانهيار
البرامج الوطنيه دي زي ما بيقول ريتشارد
ابو العافيه مدير التنفيذ لشركه
الاستشاريه الامريكيه من اهمها تقليل
ميزانيات الدفاع في معظم الدول بعد انتهاء
الحرب البارده وبالتالي سوق المقاتلات
النفاثه نفسه بدا يصغر برضو طيب لو انت
دوله غير امريكا وروسيا وكنت مصر تعمل
المقاتله النفاثه بتاعتك برده هتعمل ايه
وكنت هتنجح ولا لا بصوا خلونا ناخد
نموذجين مهمين لازم نبص عليهم ونركز معاهم
جدا اليابان وفرنسا لو بصينا على اليابان
هنلاقيها مثال كويس على عدم نجاح برنامج
وطني لصناعه طائرات مق في التسعينات
اليابان صرفت مليارات الدولارات على تطوير
ميتسوبيشي اف2 الطياره دي كانت تصنيع
مشترك بين شركه ميتسوبيشي اليابانيه بنسبه
60% والوكيت مارتن الامريكيه بنسبه 40%
والمطلوب كان نسخه يابانيه من الاف 16
الامريكيه اليابانيين كانوا عاوزين يبنوا
طياره من الاول للاخر علشان يطوروا مهارات
المهندسين بتوعهم والموضوع كمان كان واعد
وحماسي بالنسبه لهم خصوصا بعد تجربتهم في
بناء اول طياره يابانيه وهي ميتسوبيشي اف
واحد على الناحيه التانيه امريكا ما كانتش
راضيه عن الوضع ولسان حالها كان بيقول ما
تشتروا يا جماعه الاف 16 وخلصونا والضيق
الامريكي ده زاد مع الحاح وضغط اليابان
الحليفه علشان تنقل تكنولوجيا تصنيع
وتشغيل انظمه الاف 16 للمقاتله اليابانيه
طبعا التهريج ده مستمرش كتير اليابانيين
ادركوا بعد سنين انهم بيعيدوا اختراع
العجله وبيضيعوا فلوسهم علشان ينتجوا
طياره هي نسخه من الامريكيه ولكن بمسمى
ياباني وعرفوا ان امريكا مستحيل تديهم
التفاصيل التكنولوجيه اللي هم عاوزينها
علشان كده صنعه 98 طياره بس من ميتسوبيشي
اف اثنين والانتاج اتوقف سنه 2011 ورجعوا
تاني يعتمدوا بشكل كلي على المقاتلات
الامريكيه لدرجه انهم تعاقدوا سنه 2020
على شراء 147 طياره اف 35
ب23 مليار دولار لكن هل معنى كده ان
اليابانيين تخلوا عن حلم امتلاك طياره
مقاتله يشتركوا في صناعها ويكون عليها ختم
صنع في اليابان لا لسه وده بالمناسبه هو
الحلم اللي المملكه السعوديه عاوزه تشترك
في تحقيقه معاها باي طريقه وهنجي له بعد
شويه ان شاء الله بالنسبه لفرنسا فالوضع
مختلف جدا عن اليابان فرنسا من اكتر من 70
سنه وهي عندها صناعه الطيران متطوره
وشركات صناعات عسكريه عالميه اهمهم ده صوت
لكن الطياره اللي عاوزين نركز عليها اللي
نقدر نعتبرها خليفه طيار اداس ومراجعه
2000 المعروفه البحريه الفرنسيه اتبنت
الرافال لاول مره سنه 2004 ومن وقتها ومع
مرور الزمن بدات تستحوذ على حصه كبيره في
سوق الطيارات المقاتله علشان كده طلبات
شراء الرفاعي في ارتفاع مستمر من 2015 من
ساعه اول صفقه لما القوات الجويه المصريه
اشترت اول دفعه من المقاتله الفرنسيه
تتباع لدوله اجنبيه في السنين اللي فاتت
شركه داسو الفرنسيه اللي بتصنع الرافال
بتتفوق بها على كل الشركات العالميه في كل
المناقصات اللي عملتها اي دوله باستثناء
شركه لوكت مارتن اللي بتصنع الاف 35 ودول
بيلعبوا في مستوى تاني لوحدهم عاوزه اقول
لكم ان طلبات رافال في نهايه السنه اللي
فاتت 2022 وصلت لوحده وعشرين مليار يورو
يا اخوانا وده كان السبب الرئيسي في
استحواذ فرنسا على حصه مقدارها 11% او 27
مليار يورو من مبيعات الاسلحه العالميه
نفس السنه فرنسا برده بتستغل حاليا حاله
عزوف عدد مش قليل من الدول عن شراء
الطائرات الروسيه طب ليه علشان العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه طبعا وعلشان شراء
الاسلحه الروسيه دلوقتي معناها علاقات
امنيه وعسكريه اقل مع الدول الغربيه
وعلاقات سياسيه متوتره وفي نفس الوقت في
موجه صاعده في العالم حاليا بين عدد من
الدول اللي عاوز يطلع بره دايره الاعتماد
الكامل على التيارات والاسلحه الامريكيه
فاكرين لما قلت لكم في الاول شراء طياره
مقاتله مش معناها انك بتشتري طياره بس اهو
اللي بيحصل تجسيد عملي للمبدا ده فرنسا
لقيتها فرصه عظيمه من ناحيه تاخد بها نفوز
ومن ناحيه تانيه تهبش منها شويه مليارات
وعلشان كده رئيس التنفيذ لشركه داسو
للطيران زراع مجموعه داسو لصناعه الطائرات
الف يونيو اللي فات ده انه في دول مش
عاوزه تشتري طيارات روسيه ولا امريكيه
فاحنا كفرينسيين ممكن نبقى الخيار اكثر
حياديه بالنسبه لهم ولو بصينا هنلاقي ان
كلامه مظبوط بشكل ما من شهر مثلا الهند
اتفقت انها هتشتري للبحريه بتاعتها 26
طياره رافال في صفقه هتوصل ضمن اسلحه
ثانيه منها غواصات لعشره مليار دولار
تقريبا والرافال هنا كسبت المنافسه ضد
طياره بوينج الامريكيه سوبر هورنت اللي
معظمنا شافها في فيلم ودي مش اول صفقه
رفال فرنسيه للهند في 2016 القوات الجويه
الهنديه اشترت 36 طياره رافال بقيمه 8.8
مليار دولار واستلمتهم كلهم فالزبون
الهندي تحديدا هو زبون نقطه بالنسبه
لفرنسا حاليا لانه كمان هيشجع زباين او
دول تانيه انها تشتري الرافال ومعها
علاقات كامله بفرنسا علشان كده في مسؤول
فرنسي قال لصحيفه فيوليو اللي فات ان
الصفقتين دول بيعززوا مكانه الهند كعضو
رئيسي فيما يمكن تسميته دلوقتي بينادي دول
الرفع النادي ده بيضم حاليا الهند مصر
والامارات العربيه المتحده وقطر واليونان
وكرواتيا واندونيسيا ودي دول مالكه للرفال
او وقعت عقود بالفعل لامتلاكها زي
الامارات اللي وقعت عقد شراء 80 رافال في
ب19 مليار دولار وده هيخليها اكبر مشغل
لرفال في العالم بعد فرنسا نفسها
والفرنسيين متفائلين ان السعوديه والعراق
وماليزيا وكولومبيا في الطريق النادي ده
بالنسبه للفرنسيين وحسب كلامهم هو محور
سياسي مهم جدا يقدروا يشتغلوا على تحالفات
استراتيجيه معه على كل المستويات ده معنى
انك تصنع طيارتك المقاتله مش مجرد طياره
وانما علاقات كامله بس برغم النجاح
الفرنسي ده الا ان امريكا لسه لها وضعها
برضو وما تتقارنش خالص باي دوله يعني مثلا
عمليات تسليم وطلبات الرفاعي على مستوى
العالم من 2015 ولحد النهارده حوالي 500
طياره بس الرقم ده هو نص عدد طيارات الاف
35 اللي امريكا هتسلمها بنهايه السنه دي
2023 وهو اقل برضو من مبيعات سوبر هورنت
بتاعه 16 الاقدم بتاعه لوكد مارتن الحاجه
التانيه لتسويق الرفايل في اوروبا صعب جدا
بصوا يا جماعه في ثقافه اوروبيه تقيله
وراسخه جدا اسستها الولايات المتحده في
القاره ايه هي ان امريكا هي الضامن الاول
والاهم للامن الاوروبي دي القناعه
الاوروبيه الصلبه جدا علشان كده بنلاقي
السنه اللي فاتت مثلا 2022
المانيا طلب الطيارات ايه في 35 الولاء
الامريكي ده بيجنن الفرنسيين اللي عندهم
قناعه ان اوروبا لازم تبقى للاوروبيين
طبعا القناعه الفرنسيه دي ما بتطلعش غالبا
غير لما يكون في فلوس ونفوز بس علشان كده
ده سولفرنسيه اللي بتصنع رافال كانت في
قمه الغضب لما حاولوا يقنعوا بلجيكا تشتري
الرافال في 2018 فبلجيكا ده كلام جميل
خالص وطياراتكم دي حلوه جدا طب الشيكه
اشترت بعد كده ابدا راحت على طول اشترت 34
طياره اف 35 من
وهتبدا تستلمهم السنه دي الهيمنه
الامريكيه دي تخلينا نسال سؤال مهم جدا هي
ازاي امريكا اكلت تورته تسوق الطائرات
المقاتله العالمي من زمان امريكا في اواخر
الثمانينات عملت خطه ذكيه جدا تخليها تنتج
طيارات نفاثه متعدده الاستخدامات واتبعها
للكل يعني تودي الطياره لاي بلد وتظبطها
على حسب احتياجات الامن القومي والدفاعي
للبلد دي وفي نفس الوقت امريكا كمان تقدر
تتحكم في قدرات الطياره على حسب بقى
الدوله اللي هتشتري منها دي هل هي قريبه
من السياسات الامريكيه ولا لا علشان كده
في الفتره دي الاف 16 اللي هي من انتاج
لوكيت مارتن اكبر شركه صناعات دفاعيه في
العالم سيطرت على السوق العالمي وعملت
ارباح مهوله لامريكا مقارنه بتكاليف
صناعتها الاقل خاصه وانها اتباعت بدون
التزام امريكا مسبق بتحمل تكاليف تطويرها
وصيانتها علشان اديكم مثال واضح على هيمنه
امريكا على السوق العالمي للطائرات
المقاتله وهيمنه القفص 16 على الانواع
التانيه بما فيها الامريكيه واللي
بالمناسبه لسه عدد كبير من الدول
بيستخدمها لحد دلوقتي هنلاقي انه ما بين
1991 و 1995 الدول الغربيه مجتمعه انتجت
1667 طياره مقاتله 727 من الطيارات دي
كانت اف 16
و597 من انواع امريكيه تانيه
والثلاثه واربعين طياره الباقيين انتاج
دول تانيه غير امريكا يعني عندنا
1324 طياره امريكيه صنع من اجمالي
1667 طياره امريكا اكيد ما وقفتش على كده
علشان كده هنلاقيها بتطور في برنامج جونتس
اللي بيعتبر اغلى برنامج صناعه اسلحه في
التاريخ من اكتر من عشرين سنه البرنامج
الانتج للعالم اكتر مقاتله متطوره
تكنولوجيا وهي الاف 35 ايه قصه البرنامج
الرهيب ده اللي حصل انه في 2001 وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون راحت للجماعه
بتوع لوكيت مارتن وقالوا لهم والله يا
اخوانا احنا عاوزين نشتغل على مشروع ضخم
هيكسبكم فلوس للصبح طبعا عاوزين ايه يا
جماعه قال لك عاوزين طياره لها ثلاث
طرازات تنفع في التلات اسلحه الرئيسيه في
الجيش بتاعنا سلاح الجو والبحريه ومشات
البحريه اللي هم المارينز امين امين وعلى
سنه 2015 البرنامج انتج اول طراز من
الطياره السفاحه دي الاف 35 في خلال
السنين دي البرنامج تم تعميمه على معظم
الولايات الامريكيه فهنلاقي في كل ولايه
شركات ومزوده خدمات محليين بيشتغلوا فيه
وانضم ليه بعد كده 14 دوله باجمالي 1500
شركه مزوده حول العالم تكلفه البرنامج ده
لاحتياجات الجيش الام بس على مدار عمر
الاسطول الافتراضي هو 60 سنه هتعدي لوحده
نص التريليون دولار وبعض التقديرات
بتوصلها كمان لواحد فاصل سبعه تريليون
دولار في خلال الخمس او سته عقود الجايين
وبعيدا عن احتياجات الجيش الامريكي الضخمه
دي ففي 18 دوله من النرويج في الشمال
الغربي لكوريا الجنوبيه في اقصى الشرق اما
استلموا بالفعل الاف 35 او واقفين في
الطابور منتظرينها طب احنا كامريكا عملنا
ارباح بمليارات الدولارات وسيطرنا لفتره
طويله على سوق الطيارات المقاتله الخطوه
الجايه بقى امريكا حاليا وبعد فتره طويله
من الهيمنه بتدي اولويه لتطوير طيارات
نفتها مقاتله متخصصه بدل الطيارات متعدده
الاستخدامات الموجهه للتصدير هدفها
الاساسي من ده هو تجهيز جيشها بشكل افضل
لمواجهه صعود القوى العظمى الجديده بنتكلم
تحديدا عن خصمها اللدود لكن سياسات واشنطن
الدفاعيه دي
تبدو ان هيكون لها تمن فادح وهتيجي بنتيجه
عكسيه وهي ببساطه تضاؤل الهيمنه الامريكيه
على سوق المقاتلات النفاثه العالمي لاننا
حاليا في حقبه ما بعد بعد الحرب البارد
ايوه اتنين بعد زي ما سمعت يعني ايه اشرف
يعني وقت الحرب البارده زمان كانت الدول
راضيه عن شراء الطائرات الجاهزه عاوزين
خيارات سريعه ومتطوره وعاوزين علاقات مع
قطب من القطبين العالميين لكن حاليا الوضع
مختلف خالص ومع دخول منافسين جدد لسوء
صناعه وتصدير الطائرات المقاتله هنلاقي ان
الاف 35 رغم تكاليفها المهوله مش كفايه
علشان تاخد قطاع صناعه الطائرات المقاتله
الامريكيه للمستقبل او تخليه يحتفظ
بهيمنته لفتره ابعد ما بين سنه 2035 و2040
هنلاقي ان سوق المقاتلات العالمي وسوق
الصناعات الدفاعيه بشكل عام هيكون في
لاعبين اكتر لصالح هيمنع امريكيه اقل لان
هو مش هتعتمد على الطائرات المقاتله
الامريكيه للابد زي ما وضحت والحقيقه ان
ده توجه عالمي كشفته حرب روسيا واوكرانيا
والحرب التجاريه بين امريكا والصين في
الحربين دول امريكا استخدمت جزء من قبضتها
وقوتها المهوله لضرب روسيا والاقتصاد
الصيني بلا رحمه اللي حصل ده خلى فيه شعار
واحد تقريبا بيدور في ذهن كل حكومه في اي
دوله في العالم المتغطي بامريكا عريان
فاكرين اليابان اليابان زي ما قلت لكم من
الدول اللي متخلتش عن حلمها ببناء طيارتها
المقاتله الخاصه رغم اعتمادها شبه الكامل
على المقاتلات والتكنولوجيا الامريكيه
علشان كده هنلاقي انه في اواخر السنه اللي
فاتت اعلن رؤساء وزراء اليابان وبريطانيا
وايطاليا عن برنامج القتال الجوي العالمي
الجديد المعروفه اختصارا بتجي كاب وهو اول
برنامج عسكري ثلاثي على الاطلاق لاي دوله
فيهم واللي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مهتمه جدا جدا
الشريك فيه ايه بقى البرنامج ده البرنامج
ده هو برنامج تاريخي لتطوير وصناعه مقاتله
من الجيل السادس تكون جاهزه على سنه 2035
وهو نتاج لدمج برنامج
تمباستل البريطاني لانتاج الطياره
المستقبليه دي والهدف انه على سنه 2040
لندن طوكيو تحديدا
هيتوقفوا تماما عن شراء طيارات الاف 35
واليوروفه وقواتهم الجويه هتعتمد على
الطياره دي السؤال هنا بقى ليه اليابان
خدت الخطوه التاريخيه دي وهي القافله على
نفسها دايما ليه راحت للانجليز
والايطاليين رغم انها اكبر حليف لامريكا
في اسيا ومن اهم حلفائها في العالم
اليابان قالت لك احنا حبايب مع الامريكان
وكل حاجه بس الولاء الكامل ده كان زمان في
المساحات العسكريه والامنيه حاليا الولاء
ده تاخده كده وترميه ورا ضهرك في شويه
اسباب محترمه هي اللي خلت اليابان تطلع من
اوضتها مقفوله عليها اولا وعلى عكس
التعامل الامريكي الرخم المعتاد بريطانيا
عرضت على اليابان التعاون في البحث
المشترك والتصميم الاساسي لمحرك الطياره
والرادار دول مساحتين اليابان كانت مقيده
فيهم جدا جدا اثناء تطوير طارتها
ميتسوبيشي ايفيت علشان كده اليابانيين
متفائلين انهم هيكونوا شريك مساوي
لبريطانيا على عكس امريكا اللي بتميل
للهيمنه التامه على مشاريعها الدفاعيه
المشتركه مع اي دوله تانيه حتى لو حليفه
علشان تحتفظ بتفوق تكنولوجي وعسكري دائم
وده تقدر تشوفه في الرفض الامريكي الدائم
لمشاركه شفره المنبع او كود المصدر وده
كود مستحيل تقدر تعدل على اي طياره حديثه
او تطورها من غيرهم ثانيا بقى اليابانيين
عندهم طموح يبنوا طياره اقوى متطوره اكتر
من الاف 35 الامريكيه واليوروت ايفون
الاوروبيه كدول فاليابان وبريطانيا تحديدا
عاوزين مقاتله شبحيه تقدر تمارس مهمات
مختلفه بمدى ابحار طويل شويتين وبمحركات
مزدوجه وتقدر تشيل عدد كبير من الصواريخ
المختلفه بس عاوزين كل ده بتكاليف اقل من
التكاليف الخرافيه بتاعه الاف 35 خاصه ان
تكلفه تطوير طيارات مقاتله جديده هو شيء
صعب وغالي جدا صعب دوله واحده تغطي الفلوس
المطلوبه الا في حالات استثنائيه نادره
ثالثا بقى اليابان وبريطانيا وايطاليا
عندهم تصور انه من خلال التطوير المشترك
وتقليل تكلفه الانتاج الضخمه هيقدروا
يزودوا عدد الطيارات المنتجه وده هيخليهم
يقدروا يبيعوا طيارات الجيل السادس دي
لدول تانيه زي ما بتعمل امريكا فالخطه
البريطانيا وايطاليا يبيعوا للاسواق
الاوروبيه واليابان تبيع للاسواق الاسيويه
خاصه دول جنوب شرق اسيا طب دي اسباب
اليابان ايه اسباب بريطانيا اللي هي تعتبر
اهم حليف لامريكا في العالم بلا منازع
العقيده الدفاعيه البريطانيه المعروفه
باسم التدقيق المتكامل وال 12 سنه 2021
بتوضح ميل الانجليزي للتحالف واقامه
شراكات مع دول المحيط الهادي او المطل
عليه وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وكندا ده توجه بريطاني قومي من
زمان وبديهي اكتر بعد خروجهم بالاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن العقيده دي بيعاد صياغتها
حاليا بسبب الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا وده
غالبا هيرجع بريطانيا تاني بشكل جزئي
للحصيره الاوروبيه علشان كده هنلاقي ان
لندن كانت خصصت اتنين مليار جنيه استرليني
لبرنامج وده مبلغ اساسي وضروري للاحتفاظ
بالبريطانيين اصحاب المهارات التقنيه
واصحاب الوظائف القتاليه الجويه السياديه
خبرات كانت ممكن تضيع وتتبخر بعد خروج
مقاتله يورو تايفون من الخدمه خصوصا وان
مفيش ميزانيه او مشروع جامع يشغلهم الحاجه
ان البرنامج ده هيكون مفيد للاقتصاد
البريطاني في سنه 2021 شركه برايس ووتر
هاوس كوبرز توقعت ان برنامج
هيوفر حوالي 21 الف وظيفه سنويا بحلول سنه
2050 وحيساهم باكتر من 26 مليار جنيه
استرليني في الاقتصاد علشان ده كله واكتر
السعوديه مهتمه جدا جدا تدخل في المشروع
ده كشريك ممول على الاقل السعوديه من
يناير اللي فات وهي بتضغط على التلات دول
بريطانيا وايطاليا موافقين بالفعل مبدئيا
على فكره عضويه السعوديه وشايفين ان
مشاركه المملكه في التمويل هيزق المشروع
لقدام في المقابل في اليابان ما زالت
معترضه وعاوزه المشروع في اطاره الحالي
لكن الطلب المباشر بالانضمام للمشروع اللي
قدموا عليه العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
الشهر اللي فات لما التقوا في جده ممكن
يسرع الموافقه اليابانيه لكن مش ده
المشروع الوحيد في اوروبا برده في مشروع
تاني فرنسا نفسها طرف فيه ويعتبر حاليا هو
اكبر برنامج صناعه اسلحه في اوروبا اسمه
نظام القتال الجوي المستقبلي والمعروفه
اقتصارا بايه في كاس وده مشروع بين
المانيا وفرنسا واسبانيا لانتاج طائره
مقاتله جديده من الجيل السادس اطلقته
برلين وباريس في 2017 وانضمت لهم اسبانيا
في 2019 المشروع ده تكلفه المبدئيه 3.8
مليار يورو وهيكون تحت اشراف فرنسي كامل
بعد حل الخلافات اللي كانت معطله اواخر
السنه اللي فاتت 2022
وبيشمل انتاجه تطوير طائرات ماهوله ودرونز
وتطوير شبكه اتصالات فضائيه وتقنيات تخفي
شبحيه جديده لكن اهم ما في طبعا هو
المقاتله المنتظره المشروعين دول سواء جي
كاب او اف كاس بيعكسوا غضب الجميع تقريبا
من ضوابط التصدير الامريكيه الصارمه على
التكنولوجيا العسكريه واللي في احيان كتير
بتخلي مالكي ومشغله الطائرات الامريكيه زي
الاف 35 ما بيعرف يكيفوها مع احتياجاتهم
الامنيه والعسكريه طبعا امريكا كالعاده مش
ساكته قبل الجميع ومن 2014 فهي شغاله على
برنامج لانتاج مقاتلات جيل سادس ماهوله
واليه البرنامج اسمه الجيل القادم من
الهيمنه الجويه او انجات وبالفعل الولايات
المتحده بنت اول طياره في البرنامج ده
واختبرتها في طيران حقيقي في 2020 الطياره
دي المفترض انها هتكون بديله للاف 22 اقوى
طياره مقاتله في العالم طياره الجيل
السادس الامريكيه الجديده دي بيتوقع ان
سعرها هيتراوح بين 200 و 300 مليون دولار
الطياره الواحده ده اغلى من اغلي طياره
مقاتله حاليا بحوالي الضعف لكن المتوقع
برده ان الطياره نفسها مش هتبقى متاحه
للتصدير زيها زي الاف 22 وده اللي مخلي
الدول اللي فوق بتسارع في برامجها
ومشاريعها الخاصه على الجانب التاني الصين
وروسيا بيطيروا حاليا مقاتلات من الجيل
الخامس جه عشرين وجيه 31 الصينيه واسيو 57
الروسيه والسنه نفسها كشفت عن نموذج
لمقاتلات جيل سادس بتطورها حاليا ورغم انه
في شبه اجماع على ان الطيارات الامريكيه
متفوقه بمراحل عنهم لكن الصين بتقطع خطوات
معتبره في المساحه دي عكس روسيا اللي
بيقبلها الصعوبات الاقتصاديه وعدم وجود
قدره ماليه ونشغلها بحرب اوكرانيا السن
لوحدها كده محتاجه حلقه عن جيشها
وميزانيته هنعملها قريب ان شاء الله طبعا
زي ما قلت في البدايه خالص في محاولات على
نطاقات صغيره في تركيا وكوريا الجنوبيه
وحتى تايوان لانتاج مقاتله محليه ولو
بصينا على اوروبا هنلاقي السويد بالفعل
عندها مقاتلتها ساب جاز 39 جرام ورغم ان
امريكا بتخسر هيمنتها بالتدريج على السوق
ده زي ما وضحنا الا ان الهيمنه دي هتفضل
لعقود قادمه بس في مساحات تانيه زي
الفوارق ما بين قوه وتقدم الطائرات وزي ان
شركاتها الكبرى وعلى راسهم بوينج
هيفضل لهم نصيب الاسد من تورته سوق
المحركات وبعض اهم الاجزاء الالكترونيه
وده ياخدنا للسؤال الاخير في حلقه
النهارده ايلون ماسك كان في ندوه في قلب
القوات الجويه وبيتكلم قدام الطيارين
الامريكيين وقال لهم انه بيتوقع انتهاء
عصر الطائرات المقاتله بطيار لصالح الالات
او الطائرات بدون طيار فهل توقع ده صحيح
الحقيقه اه ولا مع بعض يعني ماسك عنده حق
في ان الالات تحديدا الطائرات بدون طيار
بمختلف الامكانيات هتاخد مساحه اكبر لكن
هيظل دور الطائره المقاتله بالعنصر البشري
اساسي جدا لفتره طويله علشان كده المجمع
الصناعي العسكري الامريكي والمهتمين
بانتشار الالات شايفين انه في طريق جديد
محدش اختبره لحد اللحظه هو دمج الخبره
البشريه بالاله وده هيخلي فيه مساحه
مختلفه ما فيش جيش في العالم اختبارها قبل
كده وده مش كلامي بالمناسبه وانما كلام
ستيفندلي قسم الانظمه المعتمته في شركه
كراتوس الامريكيه للحلول الامنيه
والدفاعيه علشان كده انا متبني لوجهه
النظر اللي بتقول ان المستقبل للدمج بين
الاله والبشر على الاقل في المستقبل
القريب انه يبقى في فريق طياره مقاتله
بطيار بشري ومعها فريق مصاحب من الطيارات
بدون طيار كده بقى عندك فريق عمليات
متكامل باقل الخساير البشريه لكن بدون
استبعاد عنصر التعامل البشري المباشر اللي
حتى الان مازال يحتفظ بتفوقه الكامل في
التعامل
وتحليل البيانات من ارض المعركه واتخاذ
القرار بشكل اكثر احاطه من الدرونز اللي
بتخضع للتحكم البشري بعيد المدى مع هامش
خطا اوسع ده بالمناسبه اساس برنامج انجاد
واساس برنامج سكاي بورد مشروع الامريكي
لانتاج طائرات غير ماهوله درونز تشتغل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وتقدر تطلع تساند
الطائرات المقاتله لكن اجمالا فقدان
لمساحه انها تكون المورد الاول للطائرات
القتاليه في العالم
وبفارق واسع معناه المباشر وغير المباشر
فقدانها لجزء من نفوذها السياسي والامني
عالميه لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي طولت عليكم
لكن موضوع النهارده مهم جدا وكان لازم
اشرحه بالتفصيل وكالعاده في النهايه عندي
سؤال لحضراتكم تفتكروا ممكن نلاقي دوله
عربيه قريب بتصنع طائرات مقاتله واسلحتها
بشكل كامل ولا ده صعب وايه هي الدوله دي
تابع كل اجاباتكم في التعليقات عرفونا لو
عايزين تشوفوا حلقه الجيش الصيني اللي
عايز يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا
شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه ويا ريت لو
عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو
واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا
يمكن يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]